the trump administration is speeding up
executions
of people who have been on death row
some of them for 20 years or more
and they're speeding them up because joe
biden wants to let all these criminals
off the hook
last night they killed this guy brandon
bernard brandon bernard was convicted in
the year 2000
of abducting and robbing two youth
pastors who had offered him a ride who
had actually done him a favor
uh robbed them stuffed them in a trunk
drove all around for hours
sold their wedding rings and things like
that tried to pawn off all their goods
then as they were begging for mercy and
begging for their lives and reading the
bible
uh he his buddies this whole group of
guys shot them
uh to death but the woman actually
didn't die yet and then brandon bernard
set the car on fire and she burned alive
that guy has to be executed by the state
if if
criminal justice has any meaning at all
that guy's got to be executed there was
a last-minute call
including from people on the right to
give him a pardon
or delay his execution that is a bad
idea
he rightly was executed as quickly as
possible
given the circumstances and may god have
mercy on his soul i think some people
have the wrong
impression that i am bloodthirsty for
the death penalty i'm eager i love the
death penalty i'm so
thrilled when the death penalty happens
i do in a sense i guess i love the death
penalty i
i love it in that i i know that the
state
must exact justice that is the role of a
state
but i don't get giddy you know when
criminals
are killed that that's not the issue
i am pleased when justice is done
because justice
must be done in this system i have no
personal
ill will toward this guy brandon bernard
apparently
he turned his life around while in
prison you know and kind of
death row really did something for him
and it really changed his mind and
i don't know his religious thinking by
the end of his life but he really did
turn around that's not an argument
against the death penalty that's an
argument for the death penalty
because the death penalty obviously is
retributive the death penalty is
obviously deterrent
and apparently the death penalty is
rehabilitative too
because this guy facing his own
mortality
turned his life around that's very good
and so the appropriate
response to this sort of thing is not to
say that
vicious awful terrible people who commit
awful vicious terrible crimes like
monsters
should get off the hook that's not the
answer that's extraordinarily unjust
and there is a role for mercy in a in a
civil society
but there is not a role to
to have no justice whatsoever that would
be great that would be a perversion of
society
so that's not the risk and the response
is also not yeah go get i'm so glad
you're being killed
the response is the guy committed this
crime in
certain particular heinous crimes must
meet with the ultimate
penalty and we should pray for his soul
it's a good thing it's a good thing for
everybody involved
a materialist culture doesn't quite
understand that but that is a good thing
there's a guy that's going to be
executed today
hopefully we all hope uh because there's
probably going to be another push to get
him off the hook too he uh
sexually abused his two-year-old
daughter and then tortured her and
killed her
because she knocked over her training
potty that guy obviously has to die
i don't i by the way i don't think
there's evidence that he has had any
particular change of heart
i think he remains unrepentant i could
be wrong about that it doesn't really
matter either way
that guy must be executed quickly and we
should pray that god have mercy on his
soul
capital punishment is pro-life a society
has the right to defend itself
simple as that a society has the right
to exact
justice that is pro-life